[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
au racisme est absolument une
entreprise mondiale que les employés peuvent combattre aux
États-Unis
[Musique]
nous avons ajouté des décennies de modèles à venir, nous
ne pouvons pas  entendre Laban ouais
chaque machiniste comme maniaque s'est retrouvé du
côté de la police et le service sous la police
s'excuse
[Musique]
son ​​passé est aussi unique qu'était le
bureau du pasteur de la justice mamita Lumira
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même comme en Finlande tu sais  il y a
partout dans le bar des
patrons de clubs de centres commerciaux partout vous
savez donc je pense que c'est quelque chose
comme vous savez que nous nous sommes battus il y a
de nombreuses années vous ne savez pas seulement cela
s'est passé en Amérique c'est arrivé dans tout
le pays partout  le monde, même
dans notre pays, c'est juste une
chose répétitive qui se produit constamment
parce que c'est coloré ce schéma, mais l'
Afrique a vécu sous beaucoup de
brutalités policières depuis son histoire, j'ai
été tellement normalisé dans notre pays pour
la police
comme un corps brun  sous couvert de
liberté sous couvert de démocratie
[Musique]
si Thomas dort déjà et que Taureau est
le plus impressionnant sur tanto tanto peso pour
Kahless
[Musique]
la plupart d'entre eux sont alors beaucoup refroidis et
rompus avec le DA qui a tout fait et
moi  bienvenue Tammi et
nutrimeal bonheur absolu Elena et
c'est n'importe quelle carte que la route du Sénat Elena
nous avons Tim Elaine et la pensée de
McKinley se présentent à Moscou moi macula
se présentent à Makaha D maintenant laissez-vous dégrader
notre à la démocratie aujourd'hui nous avons le droit
de parler  le premier amendement c'est
bon
tu veux te battre selon la loi tu veux
arrêter la loi toi tout seul
[Musique]
toi